سجينات ايرانيات تجاوزن ال 60 من العمر
وجميعهن محكوم عليهن بالسجن لعشر سنوات
واكثر من نصف هؤلاء امهات وفق تقرير لمركز
المدافعين عن حقوق الانسان في ايران الذي
فضح حقيقه ما يجري داخل سجن الجن في
العاصمه طهران التقرير كشف مشاهدينا ان
بعض السجينات الايرانيات يعان تعانين من
امراض خطيره وحياتها هؤلاء مهدده بالموت
يوما بعد يوما حيث يتركنا من دون علاج
داخل جدران السجن القمع داخل العنبر العام
للنساء لسجن ايفين وصفه التقرير حقوقي
بانتهاد جسيم لحقوق الانسان وان اقل ما
يقال عنه انه غير انسانيه بسبب التعذيب
والتهويل والحبس في الانفرادي لمده طويله
بعد تشكيل ملفات قضائيه لهن من قبل
السلطات الايرانيه عدد السجينات 61 واخر
السجينات صحيح الصحفيه مليكه هاشميه التي
اعتقلها النظام بعد ما حضرت الى محكمه
ايفين للادلاء ببعض الاضاحات منذ اندلاع
الاحتجاجات الشعبيه مشاهدينا في كافه
انحاء ايران اعتقل النظام الايراني اكثر
من 70 صحفيا لا يزال نصف الصحفيين رهن
الاعتقال اما ابرزهم الصحفيتان نيلوفر
حاميدي والها محمد اللتان نشرتان طريقه
قتل الشابه مهسا امين على يد شرطه الاخلاق
وتم اعتقالهن منذ بدايه الاحتجاجات في
البلاد وحتى الساعه
قصه الفتاه الايرانيه مساء مين التي اشعلت
شراره اطول موجه احتجاجه بدات بعد
اعتقالها على يد شرطه الاخلاق ووفاتها في
16 من سبتمبر الماضي
لتمتد تظاهرات لاكثر من 150 مدينه ايطاليه
حسب المعارضه على مدار 4 اشهر السلطات
الايرانيه حاولت اخفاء تورطها بمقتل الناس
امين عبر تقرير طبي يزعم وفاتها لاسباب
الصحيه
لضربه على الراس
التظاهرات جميلات
او الى ديسمبر الماضي لاحتواء الاحتجاجات
صدر قرار بحل الشرطه الاخلاق
مصيرا ممثله